you know i thought about it as you know  a parent we have two children who are in  their 20s i thought of it as an aunt of  of of preschool children and a woman  yourself and a woman myself  and the daughter of a woman  i have never heard  such a shocking and appalling  uh  transphobic rant from the vice president  of the united  states to sit there and simply  erase  pregnant men the most marginalized  community  in the world are pregnant men  and she embraces them you are a bigot  i mean not only is she saying that this  is an issue that only affects women  because only women get pregnant  um which is which is nothing but  transphobic that's a tr it is a  transphobic conspiracy theory that only  women get pregnant